all right it's uh sunday statement draft
time i've got the trivia question if you
get it right you get the first pick if
you get it wrong i do with his eighth
win yesterday mike tomlin clinched his
13th straight non-losing season to start
his coaching career only one other coach
in nfl history has had 13 straight
non-losing seasons to start his career
who is he two hints he's not in the hall
of fame and he coached a team in the
steelers division whoa
so and it's not jim turner bum phillips
oh you know that's not a bad guess okay
that's not a bad guess marty shot in him
ah man 14 straight non-losing man that's
impressive yeah marty's one of the great
coaches in the history of the league
that nobody will ever remember because
they didn't get to a super bowl or win a
super bowl but wow i didn't even realize
that that's that's pretty impressive
yeah and you know i hate to be obvious
with these sunday statement drafts but
if we're not and we post the outcome on
instagram or twitter people are gonna be
like why did you leave the guy out gotta
start with george kiddle yeah it was the
statement of the year right fourth and
two he makes the catch right he gets
face mask then he drags a guy 20 yards
down the field while his face mask is
being grabbed completely flips a game
that was one play away from the saints
winning it it was over if the saints
make this stop and there's george kittle
and he is not gone but deep enough into
new orleans territory when you tack on
the penalty the field goal is a chip
shot relatively speaking and the 49ers
get a much-needed win they complete that
gauntlet they had the packers the ravens
and the saints the latest ever in a
season in the super bowl era that a team
had three straight opponents 80 or more
winning percentage and they come out of
it two-in-one and they almost beat the
ravens not bad yeah you're right not bad
and i mean the weather played a factor
in that ravens game too but uh the 49ers
clearly are one of the best teams in
football that was an awesome game
yesterday and i think george kittle is
safe to say he is the new best tight end
in football he has taken that manual
from travis kelsey travis kelsey's
awesome but i don't think he's george
kittle at this point um all right i'm
gonna go with bashad breeland uh the
kansas city chiefs him steve spagnolo i
mean you know the defensive coordinator
which one
breeland as well
i almost gave him the hole the defense i
almost didn't do the whole defense but
bashaw breeland specifically one okay
he's a guy that yes you've heard me in
the back in the back at times go oh gosh
and pass interference call by bashad
breeland shocker yeah he's got a lot of
those this year all right so uh i do i i
ragged at him a little bit early in the
game yesterday but whether it was the
fourth and three knock down pass one on
one with him and julian edelman that was
a great play had the interception on tom
brady earlier earlier in the game that
set up the short field for the kansas
city chiefs and helped them go up 17-7 i
believe at that point so that was huge
and uh you know you know the kansas city
chiefs defense is a bigger discussion
than just bashad breeland too you know
that was our question about the chiefs
and again i know the the patriots are
not the patriots offense that we're used
to seeing but man new england finds ways
to win in december at home and the
defense was the star of the show for the
kansas city chiefs yesterday they did a
great job and i think they are an
improving unit you did pick the chiefs
to win i'll give you that credit i
thought that the patriots after losing
to the texans they would get it together
they had to get they almost did get it
together yeah they booed off the field
at halftime by their own fans it just
tells you how long of a day it was but
the chiefs defense how can you do that
what do you mean i just how can you even
boo i mean what have they been in the
super bowl for 19 years in a row
you don't like what you see you're
paying good money quit hitting the table
you're paying good money to to go out
there and freeze your ass off on on a
sunday in december yeah and you expect
yes you expect a certain standard
how dare they lose by seven to one
he can't help it if you don't like what
you see what are you supposed to say
yes yes i know boo
i know jeter got booed he did i don't
know everybody gets boo i'm not sure if
it's you you know that got booed a lot
all right uh i i gotta go with todd
gurley yeah because even though his
numbers weren't spectacular 23 carries
four other touches
this is the straw that stirs the drink
for the rams and they have been using
the straw sparingly
and now that they're getting to crunch
time they've recognized and this isn't
sean mcvay deciding he's no longer an
idiot this was strategic this was
tactical this was we need to protect
todd gurley's knee yeah you don't say it
they don't want to say it todd gurley
doesn't like it when you talk about it
but
when he is able to carry the low that he
carried last night the rams are a
different team the question is is it too
late right they've recovered well from
that blowout loss they sustained two
weeks ago against the ravens can they
finish will it even matter they could
run the table and not get in but todd
gurley what a statement from him he is
back the rams are back
and and it's been very impressive to see
what they've done in the two games since
a loss that that where it felt like he
just wanted to go to bed just get us out
of here to recover from that
a testament to sean mcveigh's ability as
a coach he pressed all the right buttons
and they're they're fine yeah yeah i
mean it is it's mcveigh's a great leader
i mean that's what you see he brings
great energy and uh jared goffs played
well and yes getting back to todd gurley
certainly has helped them out and their
defense is you know the defense has
special players so they can make special
plays happen and they can even dominate
a team like the seattle seahawks and
russell wilson and uh that was that was
a that was a yeah that was a shocking
performance it really was i did not
expect them to run away with that
football game now it helps when you know
the seahawks drop a fourth down
conversion and another third down
conversion early in the game when you go
okay here they are going to get some
momentum and then they mess it up that
way but either way uh the rams are
clearly the better football team all
right i'm going ryan tannehill uh as far
as the statement on sunday i mean yeah i
got to i mean when you have 21
completely gonna take him i'm not saying
yeah yeah yeah you know i figured you
were taking it yeah 21 completions for
391 yards it's just that's it's hard for
me not to say that's a that's a
statement that's a strong statement and
i just think this is the difference
between why the tennessee titans of
course you know are dangerous but in my
eyes a team that's truly dangerous for
the playoffs this year because one they
got derrick henry derrick henry the dump
truck as coach dungey calls him they got
him rolling and tana hill you know i am
big into the stato of what was there to
be had and does a quarterback take full
advantage i see some games your
quarterbacks throw through 300 yards and
i go yeah that was good but there was
550 there to be had and the guy missed
throws ryan tannehill doesn't leave one
yard on the field if there's a guy open
by you know a hair he somehow gets the
ball in there and threads the needle and
throws a touchdown i mean here off his
back foot across the field to jonah
smith i mean just phenomenal that way
got to give the guy credit he didn't get
really the credit he deserved when he
was in miami and things were going well
uh and had a you know a teammates and
wife and everything bag on him which i
still don't understand uh but either way
uh he's proven a lot of people wrong
here with his little stint with the
tennessee titans he left out the best
part right his tackle oh that's
something you're gonna show in the film
room today and they're gonna go nuts
they are going to go nuts that's going
to endear himself to the football team
you're exactly right i heard you talk
about it on radio before i got in here
but i don't know if we got that play but
it was a what was it a fumble it was a
fumble and he he i can't even remember
what the heck happened there was no
interception was that there was a guy
that was rumbling bumbling or stumbling
in the end zone and here comes ryan
tannehill here it is if you're watching
on tv if you're listening on radio
screen
and and there he goes and tannehill was
determined he got blocked and he swung
around and 30 yards later boom i mean
tackle full popped him popped him and
that that is the kind of thing you're
right it will endear him to his
teammates he's playing with reckless
abandon he told me last week he
cherishes everything now yeah and he's
going to ride this as long as he can't
oh by the way he's a free agent
afterwards yeah well and i think i think
uh
i think he may sign him you better you
better resign because there's going to
be some people out there paying
attention
i agree yeah all right i gotta come up
with one more i i guess i'll i you know
i i made it a superlative but but oh you
know what you know what i i've already
gave daniel hunter some run yeah you
can't go again i gotta go phillip rivers
i gotta go phillip rivers okay 45 to 10.
yeah philip when we're ready to float
him on an iceberg yeah they're ready to
bench him for tyrod taylor tyrod taylor
played yesterday for reasons completely
opposite of what we thought the last
thing we thought is tyrod taylor is
going to be mopping up a blowout in a
good way we thought he'd be in for
philip rivers who was benched 16-22 314
yards three touchdowns and only one sack
um a
154.4 passer rating for phillip rivers a
great turnaround from him after three
tough ugly games and now they got the
vikings coming to town and they can
really kind of spoil the vikings right
they can help the other la team yeah
that's right rams fans should be very
if you're the chargers and you're just
like irritated about the way the rams
have treated you maybe you'll lay down
in this one not that the players are
going to do it but but you know from the
from the organization standpoint they
probably aren't going to be upset if the
rams stay out of the playoffs actually i
mean really it does you're competing for
dollars you're competing for fans in the
same market yeah in a year that you
don't go to the playoffs you don't want
the rams to go right but they do want to
win as many games as they can and
phillip rivers is you know this is his
swan song he's gonna go out and do
everything he can to win we saw it
yesterday austin heckler had the double
triple as mds coined that phrase a
hundred plus yards receiving 100 plus
yards rushing so much for melvin gordon
he won't be back next year when they
christen that new stadium but eckler
getting it done river's getting it done
he won't be back either but kind of a
neat way for him to begin that process
as a lot of his last few games with the
charts yeah definitely um no doubt about
it and the chargers are dangerous i mean
that's not going to be easy for your
minnesota vikings that defense and then
you know rivers and their offense they
got weapons as long as he doesn't throw
you know dumb interceptions they're
they're tough to beat all right my last
one i'm going i'm double dipping on the
game but because i think you picked the
wrong person from the game so i got to
go back to it i'm going to jimmy
garoppolo he made a statement on sunday
you know again i understand kyle
shanahan was there to make you know
design a lot of great plays but jimmy
garoppolo played awesome i don't think
anybody would have gone in that game and
went ooh if it becomes a shootout
between brees and garoppolo garoppolo
will come out on top you know that's
where i think he made a statement and
you know the big question was
excuse me as i choked on myself was
jimmy garoppolo and his ability to carry
the team uh if they fell behind in a big
moment or they couldn't you know run the
ball as dominant as we see them do well
he did he answered the belt many times
yesterday whether it was here where they
were down 20-7 one play 75 yard
touchdown i understand they had the
trick play reverse pass great job okay
hey i you know again there's there's tom
brady got trick passes yesterday uh drew
brees got trick passes from taysom hill
you know so we can't count that against
jimmy garoppolo the bottom line is he
threw for 349 yards four touchdowns and
he was 26 to 35 on the road against one
of the best teams in football and as we
know one of the toughest environments in
football he came through and that's why
it was a statement you just got to give
me i just got to give him some credit
because people have been questioning him
and uh you've been questioning him well
i get it yeah i mean i have i you know
me i keep it real yes i questioned some
of the bonehead moments he had during
the year but you know he's starting to
show me something the last four or five
weeks even the loss against the seattle
seahawks there was some bad but there
was some good two to build on hey i say
all the time teams get better as the
season unfolds players get better yeah
as the season unfolds and we're seeing
it with garoppolo i still i still need
to see a little bit more in adversity
but hey but it was a good start good
start okay
i'm a believer okay friday's a believe
it out too he wasn't a believer a couple
of weeks ago he's a believer now i like
how he tried to blame it all on us at
the end of the show what you guys didn't
believe no we're talking about you you
didn't believe jimmy garoppolo all right
uh there's your draft uh outcome george
kittletodd gurley phillip rivers for me
bashad breeland ryan tannehill jimmy
garoppolo for sims
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports